let's have a look at the one so I try to
sell nice and gently it does have these
fractures in there by the way I did be
you know under test conditions that if I
manager I've tell me but um why am in
agreement many I'm not getting any lon
oh yeah if you're not okay yeah I'm good
need you add on when everyone gives me
strange looks I get really concerned
okay sure all right so let's just walk
through this beginner and I wonder add
you're going through if you feel like
you've met an error can you work out
where and why so I'll show you what I
did hopefully in some senses I don't
need to talk through it because I heard
my working stands by itself i've
multiplied every single term by 12 what
was the purpose of that yeah I don't
like those fractions it makes it hard
for my brain these things can't interact
with each other right so I'm most
lectured by 12 and that removes all my
fraction now just have a look at these
numbers here where did they come from so
this 14 right do you see the specific
place it came from was 12 / 3 I jump
cancelled then and the three that comes
down to is coach from 12/4 now what gets
left behind is three ok after that this
next line in here all I've done is
multiply 3 4 times 4 3 x 360 take away
nine left last I checked is seven and
then the last year has to do is divide
through are you happy with that
are you talking about this lively like
the 24 why is that there yes so what
I've chosen to do and I'll agree a lot
of people what you're probably thinking
as you look at this as you say oh look
there are two fractions I maybe you even
drew that is the our old cross multiply
okay this is kind of dangerous because
you're sort of mixing up a strategy than
you would use if you had a pair of
fractions that were equal to one another
right but these are not equal to one
another one is being subtracted from the
other so it's much more like this see
this here right we don't crop multiply
it what we say is oh I want both of the
interactions to have the same
denominator so you choose something to
multiply through by and that's exactly
what I've done over here the number i
chosen is 12 and the right hand side
used to be troops so then it becomes 24
yes please wait hold up like okay I'm
for time for 60 km yes can I do my old k
/ sorry but well 19 / book yet that time
correct thank you have I outside okay
now this is a really important question
because i'm sure some people have gotten
confused on this exact points okay you
just have a look at my arm let's change
the colors later get chickens you just
have a look at this pink working off
here okay now how is this is about
whatever color it is Keyshia what I've
done here oh how is it different to what
I did in my original working in blue
okay what are those here is that can you
see that this fracture and this fraction
are actually the same fraction right
it's just that I've written them with
larger molecules and denominator it's
actually the same thing if you canceled
out then come back to full count three
okay therefore this is also the same
fraction and this number over here I
haven't touched it nothing has happened
I don't need to multiply anything
through alternatively what I've done
over here is I have changed all the
numbers 12 times 4k on three it's not
the same as 4k on 3 is 12 times bigger
so instead what I elected to do it makes
everything 12 times bigger because then
I don't have any fraction okay so I
either those will work if I had have
done this the first time at this point
of 16 k minus 9 k if you're going to be
7 k / 12 hey but look now you've got to
get rid of that 12 anyway so you get rid
of the 12 later I got rid of the 12
first eventually you can have to do it
it's just a matter of early or later are
you happy with that so they suggest yeah
let's have a look at this ship please my
diagram
ok now you sort of get like 50 50 in
terms of questions where you get handed
the diagram and questions with one of
the skills we are trying to assess is
can you understand this well enough to
make the diagram yourself because that
is its own skill do you see how I've
done it I've got a carpet ruined why
have I got a compass rose up there yeah
that's right so I can measure my angle
around it's not a measured off socks am
yeah you 12 so there would be just
always to finish this I promise every
type of discussion just not just yet
I've got my distance on there really all
you need is the bare minimum would have
been this if you had that I think that's
enough do you see I've got also
information is the question I've got the
bearing I've got the distance I've got a
and I've got the ship however i did add
on all of this extra stuff white wine i
do that because i'm using the diagram
for Part B so here's my answer you can
see what I've had to do is in my diagram
the 127 degrees is useful but it's not
inside the triangle I need so you see
what I've done right 37 is that little
angle inside the triangle that's the one
I want to work with right why if I said
cause
hahahahaha okay I've said cause because
in the Triangle the site i want is asked
off the top I labeled it because I
wonder what it is which is adjacent
vehicle as the egg laid sorry the side i
know is 78 which is a hypotenuse so
adjacent hypotenuse that's cause from
there i just crunched the numbers were
you happy with that I know I didn't
answer a particular level accuracy but
it wasn't that important all the other
stuff is earlier on with the appointment
okay let's have a look at the plate what
I do would your calculator on where I
did warn you and if you borrow
calculator it's what happens oh yeah
[Music]
I'll have a look concede upon that era
I'll have a look is doing everything
like that said oh ok so I just what you
look at my diagram have a look now the
first thing I've done is not blocking
the angle of depression DC today in blue
that is the angle i want the plants
however the angle i want is not inside a
triangle at least not yet so can you see
what I've done over here that egg was
the same why isn't saving it okay thank
you I've got parallel lines PR and
alternate angles on power lines are
equal so if i could find this one that
means i can find the angle depression
and I've done okay so then all i did was
i formed the right triangle over there
opposite on adjacent is 10 yeah so
that's the end my god
okay you close hold it there share my
simultaneous equations now we have we
have three main message to do easy you
can draw it but ain't nobody got plans
of that we can do it by substitution or
you could do it by this what have I done
starts with an E I thought to by
elimination okay so have a look why did
I do that why did I take an equation and
multiply I'm looking at the y right yeah
so popular possibly one of the top and
abideth reaiiy on the bottom about
eliminate so I just got to get the three
wire on the top that was me here right
there I got the freeway at the top don't
forget you multiply every single term by
three otherwise it doesn't stay balanced
that you multiply okay like I said that
yes no reservation as equation they want
to quite be right one was a sheer in
here well I kind of have a third
equation then but instead of coin
equation 3 I have just given a different
day but they don't remember why I gave
it this name so that i know where it
came from so I don't put it back into
itself okay because we saw how that
works I then I added them there's the
eliminated variable man the wise have
disappeared and then it goes from there
are you happy to make sir
by the way quick question before i go to
the last one once you get X you can
substitute into either equation why did
I choose equation 1 it's easier but what
makes equation 1 easy on any time no
negatives no other numbers look the way
that I want is just sitting there by
itself which is why you can see I don't
divide through by anything that have to
flip any negative sign it's just there
alright last question ok so I don't know
because I don't hear a dragon-themed ok
now changing the subject what you do the
subject is about is it at the moment the
equation is all set up so that if you
don't X and G you could find out what
tears can you just plug it in your
calculator double the work and there's
one st but supposing you don't know what
g is but you know what these guys are we
want to rearrange so what I've done is I
said ok we're just going to step by step
but just going to peel back the layers
until I can get 2g on this phone what
have I done my first one is looking
device for finding I've divided through
by 2 pi because it's just like running
through a series of titles you've gotta
run through the closer ones before you
get to the farm and the two times it
easy to get rid of so i divide it
through it ends up over here have a look
at this way when I go from one to two
what's happening I squared because I
don't want it in the way so to get rid
of square root square don't I guess you
burn why don't the pie girl took my [ __ ]
yes great question I've got a chi and a
clear head up I everything get square so
T squared sine PI squared is fine what's
this where is full so that's why this
kind of changes I've got the g looking a
lot closer what happened to write choose
to live degree weather
don't worry it has a fancy name starting
off I've taken the reciprocal you can't
is difficult one side like that you're
going to do with any other one as well
that's why they broke up side down that
egg did the way I being divided so the
opposite of dividing by X is your most
clusters plans and dangerous